o lado pessoal de quem fala em mudar
isso eu seja muito bem-vindo jamais um
vídeo mostrado aqui um vídeo e as a um
trailer do jogo fácil então sempre o
primeiro que o alto s2 e pra quem não
sabe sim vai ser o algoz de 2 este ano e
estou super ansioso por ele é chávez no
twitter o imenso as vezes que o assédio
do super financia os prejudicaram após
dois dias foi o primeiro jogo em que o
guerreiro firma seria que no canal e já
fui para a 12 anos atrás não sai 2
e pra quem não conhece o autor esta de
um jogo do que eu sabia que os jogos
bloco é o atleta está lá ensina a itown
vultoso está fax não pude estudar já o
flash não sei se eu me lembro bem da
história mas eu acho que aquilo era de
11 11 no c1 e ozil eu não sei dizer
portuguesa era um hospital por um look e
você gera um repórter que tenham que
andar lager vista e eu acho que é isso
não sei é memória tipo um país pra quem
não sabe os países um book isso eu sou
um país vai também no trailer pessoal
para lá e se coisa
bora lá só em 321 bora é a pedra
é bom a estava atingindo estado antônio
é isso que estamos pedindo uma coisa foi
feita navio não não não
ela tá muito alto que eu não estou a ver
a minha baixa 2016
ok este é o treino oficial então é é
agente promessa que ela crie do demônio
invertida com shamil isso estuda gosta e
não pessoal o que eu tinha a dizer sobre
este trailer lan não só eu até fiquei um
minuto e talvez não mostrou muito acerca
do jogo e ainda vai né porque não na
escola e tal mas pelo menos o autoestudo
fui pro pau o deus e fui pro tal meu
deus ser tão bom que nem parece não ser
a meu ver foi o oeste 2 e agora vai ser
o 3 turbo deus estava tudo para ser um
jogo bom e só o chip construído espero
que vocês tenham gostado desta reta
chances bem que não deu pra mim nestas
minute pau está entre os últimos mas
para fazer isso em estatização enquanto
o athletic por isso fique bem aí digamos
pepe era para chuva
nenhum dos comentários de vocês querem
ver uma série da flex 2 aqui no canal
quando eu sair é isso que eu falei aqui
sobre tudo fique bem até a próxima em
lei e depois o clube no cuca